Esther Dyson: Like everyone, and perhaps slightly earlier than some, I started noticing
not so much the opioid crisis, which is white people dying, but the problem of addiction.
And just how widespread it was
and it clearly was getting more widespread.
And there seemed to be some relation to that
and the the loss of jobs especially
sort of middle class or slightly lower men.
And that you can see in the statistics and so forth.
It felt kind of familiar to me it reminded me of Russia.
Where under the Soviets there were people
just doing useless jobs
and drinking themselves to death.
I asked one of my friends, I said, you know
you shouldn't smoke and drink so much
because you're gonna die early. And he said, well,
life is not so wonderful that we really care about that.
Better to drink now and be happy.
The women tended to deal with it much better.
For two reasons: one, they had children and they felt
they were important in somebody's lives
and had a purpose.
Also they took the money they
and their husbands earned
and went and stood on line and turned the money
into things that they valued.
The money itself was useless
and the jobs were purposeless.
So I started reading about addiction.
If anyone is curious, there's Gabor Maté,
there was Maia Szalavitz who wrote
a book called "Unbroken Brain."
Addiction is not a character defect,
she said, it was a learning disorder.
Then I read the book that I thought made the most sense, called "The Biology of Desire" by Marc Lewis.
He really said, that it was learning FROM disorder.
In other words, fundamentally, if you start
your life out with a lack of security
with unpredictable parents, with basically... if your brain is damaged during the first few years of life
you become vulnerable later on.
There's lots of stuff now
about adverse childhood experiences
and there's a clear correlation between adverse early childhood experiences and addiction.
obesity, dropping out of school,
abusing your own children, ending up in jail...
and so forth. So Marc Lewis,
who himself was formerly addicted,
tells the story of five people.
And, towards the end, he says I don't really know what my next book is going to be about.
But one way or another it is about time.
And in a sense foreshortening.
You lose your peripheral vision.
You're focused only on this thing you desire.
You're never satiated.
You reach for it, that's the moment of desire.
You get it and you're almost immediately
back in the cycle.
You lose a sense of time. You lose your past that was different. You lose a sense of agency.
I can have a future that's different.
He talked about Native Americans. The ones who had lost their sense of history
are much more subject to alcohol abuse
and all those familiar problems.
So I went to see him in the Netherlands, where he lives.
And, this time thing, and this short cycle...
We need dopamine. We need desire to live.
We won't do anything if we don't have a desire...
But if your desire is only short-term
and instant it, it becomes addiction.
I used to think the idea of "cell phone addiction"
was just like a clever metaphor. But, not really.
In fact, addiction is a behavior pattern.
If you're addicted to a substance that has bad physical effects (like alcohol, in particular, or drugs) it's worse.
But it's the behavior pattern
and that foreshortened cycle of
wanting something that doesn't actually
provide the relief you're seeking
much more than it is the substance
that's really at the heart of addiction.
The trick is how do you change that
short term desire which is addiction
into long term desire which is purpose?
Where there is a sense of the future and of change
and of getting some gratification
that's long-term and permanent.
Kara Platoni: So let me ask you, I think there are
some people who would say
Kara: the solution is individual.
A person has to make good choices.
They are responsible agents of their own fortune.
Addiction is a moral failing.
There are others who'd say, no, it's a structural problem.
It's a collective problem. People may not have choices. All of their choices may be bad.
Their environment may be constraining their choices.
Esther: And they're not making a stupid choice.
Esther: If you have no job why not go out and get drunk. You'll feel better.
Kara: Or why not... if the only job in your community
is to deal drugs, then you'll deal drugs.
Kara: if it's the most lucrative thing.
Esther: And that's different from addiction.
Esther: The best drug dealers are not addicted.
They're smart business people.
Kara: But the point is that your environment gives you
a certain set of choices, right?
Esther: Yes. And you can only make the choices that you have to make.
Esther: You can get into long discussions,
but fundamentally...
Esther: How many of you are AI people?
We need a better training set for infant brains.
We train our AI's. We need to figure out how
to train our children's brains.
Not with rote training,
but train them that "your mother loves you",
and that life is not totally secure,
but your parents love you and they'll take care of you.
You need to give them a sense of security,
so they can trust in the long term.
In a sense, addiction is: you've lost trust in everything but this immediate short-term source of solace.